rendez vous compte qu'on en 1926 quand
on inaugure et ici on a déjà l'eau
courante froides et chaudes
on a déjà l'électricité on a déjà un
système de chauffage centralisé
on a comme à l'eau courante on a aussi
une salle de bains et les wc à
l'intérieur de la maison
déjà grand chose d'extraordinaire un
garage un garage bonnes maisons
d'ouvriers tout ça c'est ce sont des ce
sont des détails qu'on ne trouve pas
dans une maison d'ouvriers
habituellement voilà ça vous rajoutez le
volet roulant qui est aussi une
innovation pour l'époque l'idée de
pouvoir récupérer les eaux usées dans
une cuve à désintégration chimiques tous
ces petits détails qui font de ces
maisons des maisons high tech pour
l'époque
[Musique]
oui aussi durant tout le long de la voie
de chemin de fer qui va de bordeaux
arcachon
à quelques encablures du centre de
pessac une surprise attend les voyageurs
attentif ici entre 1924 et 1926
l'architecte le corbusier a construit
une cinquantaine de maisons ouvrières
commandé par un industriel bordelais
ayant fait fortune dans le sucre on rit
frugès ce chef d'entreprise éclairée a
le génie et la prescience de commander
cette cité à le corbusier en lui
écrivant je vous autorise à réaliser vos
théorie architecturale dans leurs
conséquences les plus extrêmes
pessac doit être un laboratoire le
l'escalier en z permet d'accompagner le
regard toujours plus loin et s'arrête là
mais continue plus loin ce qui ouvre
aussi considérablement horizontalement
et verticalement aussi le z n'est
réalisé qu'avec des creux et des pleins
de l'ombre et de la lumière
il faut dire qu'henry fruges elle
s'était convaincu et séduit par les
idées de l'architecte
je l'aï d'abord non les ai joués jamais
l'appartement on a déjà fortement au sud
sud est loin
les piétons ont des chemins pour dessous
des maisons des pins plantés autour des
genoux vous pouvez faire vos retours et
vert avec nice et pourquoi est on dit de
la ville secours verdure c'est une ville
verte
construit à 12% en 1923 le corbusier est
un architecte n'ayant pas encore très
connu mais qui est vraiment sur le point
de l'être parce qu'il vient de publier
vers une architecture qui va être un
livre fondamental dans l'histoire
l'architecturé du xxème siècle entre
1923 et se disent en 1930 en moins de
dix ans le corbusier va s'imposer comme
le porte parole de l'architecturé
moderne dans le monde entier à l'échelle
vraiment internationale l'architecturé
le jeu savant correct et magnifique des
volumes a semblé sous la lumière en 1967
quarante ans après l'achèvement de la
cité qui porte son nom
henri frugès raconte sa découverte du
texte fondateur de le corbusier vers une
architecture
un jour un article me tombe sous les
yeux signé d'un nom tout à fait inconnu
le corbusier
je suis frappé par le bon sens de cet
auteur est visé comment pardon c'était
pourtant révolutionnaire l'époque
j'étais très révolutionnaire mais les
idées étaient pleines de bon sens dès le
lendemain j'étais à paris je fais la
connaissance et d'engins petit et second
étages de la rue d'astorg une toute
petite rue qui est en face de
saint-augustin je trouvais un homme
jeune trentaine d'années avec d'énormes
lunettes aux branches noir l'air simple
sympathique et la conversation s'engage
au bout d'une heure de conversation nous
y étions tous les deux d'accord est déjà
presque des amis
il n'était pas connu à l'époque il était
inconnu à cette époque
après sa rencontre avec le corbusier on
rit frugès lui confie un projet méconnu
qui va précéder celui de pessac
il s'agit de la mystérieuse cité de lège
dans la forêt landaise ici en 1923
frugès vient d'acquérir une scierie
fabriquer des caisses en bois dont il a
besoin pour sa raffinerie de sucre
il veut loger ces ouvriers sur place et
commanda l'architecte six maisons
individuelles et un dortoir pour les
célibataires
le chantier débute fin 1923 et le
corbusier y met en oeuvre ces théories
on voit apparaître les frais de bandeaux
un des points de cinq points
d'architecturé le corbusier initient des
toitures terrasses jardins bien sûr
certaines pergola la notion pilotis qu'a
été envisagé au début a été abandonnée
on avait des escaliers extérieurs aussi
qu'on était abandonné les italiens ont
été rapatriés à l'intérieur mais le
principe de plans libre avec 6,1 poteaux
poutres un escalier perpendiculaire a
été mis en oeuvre étrange maisons
cubiques qui ne manque pas de surprendre
les occupants on n'est pas sur un tissu
urbain on est patient un tissu de
pavillon
n'est pas sur une maison dans un parc on
est on est sur un ensemble de volumes
qu'on appelle maison mais qui ressemble
pas à un simple une maison c'est d'abord
un volume couvert avec un toit c'est
d'abord des murs enfin on a tous un
archétype de l'habitation en était il
n'ya plus de repères je crois qu on est
sur une perte de repères si je fais
dessiner mes enfants aujourd'hui une si
leur fait des siennes maison il me met
un toit à deux pentes dessus croisé on
veut dire ça fait vraiment partie dans
l'archétype inscrits inscrits dans
l'idée de protection qu'on a en tant
qu'individu la réaction des gens
évidemment et était un peu un peu fort
que la réaction parce que étant donné
que de voir ces maisons cinq voitures ça
choque un peu ils trouvaient ça bizarre
tout est symbole bilan de voir des
maisons carrées qui ressemblait des
coloris noir et que de cul dans les
années qui suivent qu'henri frugès et le
corbusier sont loin les habitants
reprennent les travaux en main et
transforme les lieux en ce qui leur
semble être des maisons aujourd'hui la
magie de la rénovation a fait son oeuvre
mais voilà l'état dans lequel jean luc
verrait trouve la cité 70 ans après sa
construction avant d'être chargé de sa
restauration par gironde habitat
beaucoup de garage d'appentis il avait
eu des problèmes d'infiltration au
niveau des terrasses donc la solution la
plus simple pour eux c'était de mettre
une charpente en bois il y avait du bois
à profusion maître de la tôle ondulée et
pour protéger un petit peu de temps
quand on est arrivé c'était ça c'était
une volumétrie complètement perturbé des
toitures en pente des fenêtres pareil
qui avait été rétrécie des agences en
deux volumes
et puis dans un état j'avais dire
pathologique un peu
un peu déprimant presque on avait bien
envie de trouver une fenêtre caché là
dessous on est venu avec notre petit
martonas de petits burins et on est venu
commencé à piocher tout doucement pour
essayer de dégager les huisseries et
seront effectivement qu'on en a trouvé
et qu'on a trouvé donc ces traces
visserie métallique qui sont là en
situation et par extension on a pu
entendre en tapotant publiquement
redéfinir le volume exact a fait les
proportions exactes de ce modèle de
châssis le récit de cette rénovation
allège préfigure ce que nous allons
découvrir à pessac
c'est d'autant plus étonnant que c'est
l'expérience de lège qui a donné henry
frugès l'idée dé nouveau quartier de
pessac et pessac a été en somme la
répétition générale pour le camp dès que
l'on peut des chantiers de la site de
pessac débute cours en 1924 et progresse
rapidement au rythme d'une habitation
par semaine
l'architecte pense que grâce aux
nouvelles techniques il va pouvoir
considérablement réduire les temps et
des coûts de construction
mais des difficultés techniques
retardent la réalisation des travaux
l'entreprise locale maîtrisent mal les
techniques du béton l usage du canon à
ciment américain se révèle un échec
[Musique]
de plus les autorités locales méfiante à
l'égard de l'initiative ne facilite pas
les choses pour délivrer les permis de
construire et en profite aussi pour
retarder l'adduction d'eau cependant
l'audacieux chantier progressent
[Musique]
le corbusier a conçu la structure des
maisons à partir de dalles en béton
porté par des piliers il a mis au point
un assemblage de modules standards de 5
mètres sur 5 qui permettent une
fabrication industrielle il s'agit d'une
véritable taylorisation de la
construction et l'inauguration arrive
nous sommes le 13 juin 1926 le ministre
des travaux publics anatole de monzie
inaugure les quartiers modernes frugès
les visiteurs sont surpris par l'alluré
du chantier par l'ambition des
bâtisseurs
la cité a été conçu pour résoudre les
problèmes du logement en proposant des
maisons bon marché aux familles modestes
mais frugès et le corbusier cave est ce
aussi le rêve de transformer de l'homme
et la société
[Musique]
au fil des années ce sont plutôt les
habitants qui ont transformé la cité la
bricole en l'adaptant le modifiant au
gré de leurs besoins
moi je suis sylvie gervais bridier votre
nouveau voisine je suis au 25 rue
fréchette
ça fait à peu près un an que je suis là
mais en plus je connais pas tous les
habitants corps mais ça me fait plaisir
ça va être l'occasion de ce rallye est
une des plus ancienne résidente de la
cité son père militaire de carrière il y
avait acheté un pavillon de type arcade
en 1926 ailier né en 1930
moi j'ai connu le quartier fraude j'ai
entouré de forêt y avait pas que vous
voyez en face la châtaigneraie arago
il y avait une grosse ferme
à gauche là où on allait chercher le
lait on allait chercher chez eux mais on
était aumônier de la corrida est rentré
dans la forêt pour découvrir la cité
ils ont vécu si les enfants dans une
arcade peux te faire e pour l'époque je
peux le comprendre mais à voir salle de
bal ou à terre bon c'est quand même
quelque chose de rêver pourtant les
espaces de l'intérieur conçue par le
corbusier était relativement restreint
faut dire quand même que elles sont
superbes ces maisons mais il n'y avait
pas de garage à l'origine au soleil ce
magnifique que meiway le rangement c'est
pas facile
optimiser web optimisée parce que bon il
ya des petits recoins où on arrive à
faire des aménagements voilà c'est ça
notre on nous vole c'est difficile de
cacher un aspirateur de cachets à avaler
les relais cet arrondi chez carré ça
c'est vrai c'est bon allez je vais
rentrer
toujours en décembre l'arbre là c'est le
retrouve fouet c'était la cuisine ici on
rentrait à 8,9 deux petites pièces et y
avait ici alors je ne vous explique un
père ici avec de grands scoops
cuisinière en flux continu qui chauffé
la salle à manger par des bouches de
chaleur et les chambres en euros par
contre je vis tout à l'heure sur manche
et habile ici un tout petit ailier et la
table l'homme les fenêtres avec les six
enfants ne va pas une fin on est bien
dans ces maisons bois
j'ai très très bien ça ma cheminée
centrale
oui mais j'ai pas la belle cheminée
parce que la fumée les quand j'ai fait
le travaux c'est un ami à mon avis
amélie qui retape la cheminée et
partis en vacances et l'a fait tomber la
cheminée vous faire nous a fait suite
aux grands du chahid a enlevé le
cheminot alors bon là je vais la faire
vont nous faire faire à l'origine
oui c'est comme ça depuis les escaliers
vous avez laissé la vie décès des
escaliers oui les couleurs we do when le
fait qu'ils soient pas protégés tout ça
il est vraiment l'origine l'année
scolaire - toutes les salles originaux
et sauf ce qui est derrière parce que
j'étais obligé de faire bâtir derrière
mon père étant avec 80 des gens ne
pouvais plus monter
donc j'ai fait faire une véranda une
pièce supplémentaire et une salle
debeyre voilà on est tous assez
d'origine les chambres ne rien toucher
moi je restaure collègues nous assure
que tout est d'origine qu'elle n'a rien
changé
voilà quelque chose que nous allons
souvent entendre dans la bouche des
habitants de la cité est ça qui est
extrêmement intéressante parce que les
posent énormément d'enjeux
le corbusier va ici réaliser donc une
cité de maisons ouvrières on peut dire
et le corbusier là va essayer de
répondre à la fois sur le plan des
formes inventer de nouvelles formes
sur le plan des techniques apportées les
techniques nouvelles
dans le but de d'abaisser le coût de la
construction est mais également
innover sur le plan social en proposant
mes pièces une organisation générale de
la maison qui est nouveau ici et c'est
là où il ya un enjeu énorme à pessac et
c'est aussi pour ça que pessac n'est pas
une réussite complète parce que il a
pris énormément de risques en essayant
de tout mettre dans cette heure
[Musique]
on
initialement c'est le purisme c'est un
projet théorique que le corbusier réfère
à la fois la création artistique donc à
une certaine poétique et puis aussi à la
géométrie à une certaine notion de
l'ordre à une certaine notion de
l'asymétrie du modernisme du
fonctionnalisme c'est un projet dont qui
a véritablement au départ pour fonction
de faire tabula rasa un peu soul et
odyssea de repartir sur un habitat
propres on est presque dans une
dimension humaniste
peu à peu les gens vont y trouver leur
compte
on se mettra bricoler à are en
s'acclimater à s'accoutumer de
l'existant tant bien que mal
ainsi claude goron ouvrier à la retraite
de loyer en atelier de bricolage a fini
par trouver sa place dans la cité où il
goûte aujourd'hui un repos bien mérité
d'abord à la maison chez elle et pas
tous été des locations ouais voilà
et on est mou 663 78 auquel à quel
moment un gars nord pour françois pas
que c'est à ce moment là je me souviens
tu y crois que 78 un truc comme ça vous
avez emménagé ici l'année de la mort de
claude françois
oui là je mords pas mal est là depuis 44
6 juin 46 si on arrivait de la rue le
corbusier voulait une grande sobriété
extérieur or les habitants vont très tôt
être gêné par l'absence de couleur par
l'absence de singularité la vie
quotidienne des personnes allaient à des
toujours singulières et fait
d'irrégularités et c'est toute la
difficulté est d'imposer un projet sans
irrégularités finalement avec un projet
purement fonctionnel purement esthétique
hyper théorique
les gens vont opposer leur leur briquet
leur broc leur leurs histoires de vie
finalement leur biographie
leurs histoires de vies qui vont
incarner qui vont permettre leur
permettre de de ces deux habitués de sa
coutumière c'est aux villans on n'a pas
changé non non non même peut-être que
nous on est peut-être une des maisons
qui a le moins de transformation
intérieurement attend la cheminée qui
avec ont apprécié ce parent a prôné le
plus tard trois autres choses autrement
on a toujours les on a toujours les
ouvertures et les fenêtres
c'est leur vivant puisque c'était dur
j'étais un trou quand même pas une
maison normale depuis toujours
est ce que l'on doit partir du quotidien
des personnes de leur vécu de lors de
leur désir de leur résistance de leur
douleur leur quotidien ou bien est-ce
qu'on doit essayer
al'inverse méthode plus a priori
finalement on va partir d'un projet
théorique pour le plaquer sur les modes
de vie ces deux vies deux visions du
monde en fait
et le modernisme de le corbusier c'est
précisément d'imposer à priori cette
idée de l'homme nouveau sur sur les
modes de vie
et encore ces référents noir
comme ça toute la façade sera impeccable
et quand les touristes viendront cet été
mais vers une maison qui est entretenue
c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire pour le
corbusier pour deux mandats comme coller
aux besoins comme claude goron et
d'autres encore jean cabantous salue
aussi son point de vue sur le corbusier
ils pratiquent d'infimes arrangement
avec larchitecture d origine ce qui ne
poserait aucun problème sans le
classement de la cité en zone protégée
le corbusier y propose je dirais une
solution complète propose une nouvelle
architecture avec un mode de vie qui va
avec
mais évidemment les mentalités sur la
façon de vivre évolue lentement et
encore aujourd'hui ces maisons restent
d'avant garde l'idée de l' architecture
moderne c'est de décloisonner d'ouvrir
les pièces les unes sur les autres et
cela on vient voir nos modes de vie que
tout le monde ne veut pas forcément
[Musique]
andré bidaud les directeurs d'hôpital et
son épouse sont un couple passionné et
inspiré par la pensée de le corbusier
il fréquente les nouveaux quartiers
frugès depuis le début des années 60
tout d'abord comme locataire puis à
partir de 1989 comme propriétaire
cependant une vraie vie sic depuis 2004
après avoir mené à son terme une
restauration exceptionnelle conduite
avec une grande fidélité à l'esprit du
projet aujourd'hui leur point de vue sur
l'évolution de la cité est très précis
[Musique]
quand on regarde la liste des premiers
propriétaires de la cité se sont tous je
veux dire on va dire employés petits
fonctionnaires artisans mais modeste
artisan en fait les gens qui sont
arrivés ici voulait à l'époque avait
besoin d'abord une famille étaient
beaucoup plus nombreuses dont casey des
familles avec 2,2 3,5 enfants avec deux
chambres à coucher
il s'est passé ce qui devait se passer
c'est que les gens créer des espaces en
récupérant les vide qui existe dans ces
maisons dans les jambes on bidouille et
il n'y a pas d'autre mot traficoter
cetera en plus la conception des grandes
baies vitrées terrain ne correspondait
pas la psychologie nos modes de vie des
gens ils voulaient occulter les vitres
en plus d'y ajouter les problèmes
d'infiltration d'eau et de froid donc
ils ont fermé ils ont résolu le problème
de façon très simple ou ferment les
ouvertures
monsieur vous êtes l'un des tout
premiers propriétaires marais quartier
et vous avez eu le privilège de
connaître votre architecte et charles le
corbusier et l homme était-il c'était un
homme d'aspect plutôt un peu froid mais
vous savez la conversation avec lui
c'est un homme d'abord très distinguée
et on sentait que c'était quelqu'un vous
avez une anecdote à nu portée comme un
oeil date il était venu nous trouver un
jours et puis devant le plan de la cité
quelques-uns du moins une personne avait
fait des modifications un peu trop
importante dans sa maison elle en voyant
ça que le corbusier prend le plan et de
son air énergie inscrit dessus sur le
plan naturellement exemple de mauvais
goût lui ce qu'il a cherché le corbusier
c'est à humaniser la maison à la rendre
la plus agréable possible
et il avait réussi il a été critiqué
mais par la suite on la connaît
le corbusier est arrivé lui avec une
certaine idéologie c'est à dire d'offrir
jédir un espace de vie ou rentrer la
lumière l'air et l'ouverture sur
l'extérieur et forcé un peu les gens à
s'intéresser à ce que fatalement tout
cas de dans nos petits ce cador cd
maison où je veux dire le dehors et
l'intérieur s'interpénètrent comme en
permanence
[Musique]
les cinq points d'une nouvelle
architecture sont le résumé des idées
que le corbusier développe tout au long
des années 20 les pilotis permet au
rez-de-chaussée d'être destiné à la
circulation piétonne de dégager
l'habitat du seul d'élever la maison
vers le ciel et de la rendre plus saines
ce plan libre qui vient se poser dessus
comme un premier deuxième ou troisième
étage permet le développement des
espaces à vivre sur des planchers
libérés chaque espace ayant une fonction
précise repas repos sommeil méditation
conversation lecture la façade libre
dégagée des contraintes des murs
porteurs grâce aux poteaux pilotis en
béton armé permet une plus grande
souplesse de construction favorisant les
fenêtres en longueur aux fenêtres
bandeau qui ouvre les espaces libère le
regard et permettent une meilleure
diffusion de la lumière
le toit terrasse avec son renoncement
aux toits traditionnels en pente ouvre
par son aménagement au toit jardin au
solarium à l'espace de repos
[Musique]
à la fin des années 80 cette maison est
en vente et le couple bideau les
envisage de l'acquérir
malgré son état donc on l'a acheté puis
on est parti on était dans le nord-est
et on a fait travailler monsieur verrait
pour la rénovation ma mémé tu es libre
tu sais toi parce que moi quand j'avais
vu la maison dans l'état où elle est et
j avais dit qu on va au devant d'eux une
catastrophe quoi je savais qu'elle était
bien on est devenus propriétaires en 20
89 avec l'objectif de la rénovation
[Musique]
avant de s'attaquer aux façades pourquoi
mandeville notamment dans les
embellissements c'était d'abord de
réparer les supports donc là c'est tout
ce qui touche au béton donc parmi les
premiers béton dans les années 1925 avec
une maîtrise du béton d'apparat
extraordinaire une tendance soit sur la
composition du béton proprement dit soit
sur l'emploi de fer à béton en trop
grosse quantité ou avec des enrobages
insuffisant toujours est-il et puis
rappelez des maisons qui n'ont pas été
entretenues et bien que ces bétons se
sont dégradées il se dégrade de plus en
plus vite et ça se traduit par ce qu'on
appelle les époux furent des éclats
l'eau pénètre à l'intérieur du coup ça
gonfle saf éclaté donc l'idée c'était de
réfléchir là dessus de voir à l'époque
les premiers produits qu'on pouvait
mettre en oeuvre sur la base de résine
de mortier sans retrait des choses comme
ça donc de faire appel un peu à tous
l'accès technicité à là je parle de 1996
comme le montre la halle est plutô t une
maison qui avait été transformé on
rapporte aux plans d'origine de le
corbusier mais également jédir elle
était dans un état
enfin rue de délabrement ya pas notre
mouvement il n'y avait que le haut qui
avait gardé ses ouvertures d'origine
voilà
donc en bas y avait un appartement et en
os à notre appartement
et tout ça bien sûr avec jets 10 rebonds
tous les problèmes je dire de béton et
de deux structures qu'avait su quoi mais
petit à petit ce viol est fonction de
l'avancée des travaux
eh bien c'est la reconquête des volumes
et des espaces tels que le corbusier du
traité on a posé la question plus en
acheter pourquoi la fenêtre de la
cuisine n'est pas au même niveau que les
autres priori il a descendu cette
fenêtre pour accentuer cet effet optique
de des lancements enfin bon
interprétation donc l'objectif a été
dans la mesure du possible de rénover la
maison qui avait beaucoup souffert
éventuellement décider d'investir bien
sûr laitages qui était le niveau
principal mais éventuellement d'investir
le raid chaussier et comme on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure qui était sur les pièces
de service soit une certaine
transparence on voit effectivement
plusieurs des cinq points larchitecture
de le corbusier la terrasse jardin dont
on a parlé les fenêtres en longueur que
l'on devine par ici
le plan libre la façade livres mais
aussi les pilotis parce que l'idée c'est
que ces grandes ouvertures qui ont été
provisoirement j'allais dire comblé par
les châssis transparent donner un
sensation de transparence de vide
donc on avait vraiment cette sensation
d'un étage
qui était portée par une partie avec des
pleins et des vides mais des pilotis
c'est pas nécessairement des pilotis en
ce sens deux poteaux les vider les
rez-de-chaussée
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on vient du monde entier
pour visiter la cité le corbusier de
pessac
comme chaque mois le comédien pour le
dakar
ça y est
la pop
[Musique]
et vous
m
william héros est un personnage
important dans l'histoire de la cité cet
ingénieur passionné d'architecturé tombe
sous le charme d'une maison arcade
qu'ils acquièrent en 1973 dès l'année
suivante il a restent hors de ses mains
à la le corbusier
ensuite il n'aura de cesse de courir
après une chimère pour le moins
étonnante
faire classer sa maison monuments
historiques
bon je vais fait classer tout simplement
pour essayer de faire avancer les choses
il faut quand même se mettre dans
l'esprit de ce qu'était ce quartier en
73 c'était est vendable en général
l'acheteur l'acheteur type c'était un
type qui savait bricoler qui savait
montée départ pas et puis
et donc il acheter pas cher du tout je
l'achetais 55 mille francs se sait plus
trop ce que ça représentait en 73 mais
c'était pas cher c'était même pas le
prix d'un studio dont qu'ils achetaient
ça et puis ensuite il l'a ménagé à leur
goût
mais vous l'avez aménagé selon les
concepts le corbusier
donc je les restaurer sous la direction
de j monnet le directeur de la fondation
le corbusier à l'époque et c'est pour ça
qu'elle est à peu près convenablement
restaurer je la considère comme une
oeuvre
dix neuf re d'un homme qui a une idée
globale est atteinte au moment où je le
considère comme une oeuvre comme tableau
je suis infiniment respectueux c'est à
dire qu'il faut vraiment me couper un
bras ou une jambe pour shaw modifie jal
terre il faut vraiment des raisons
manifeste de terribles pour que je
change un tout petit peu quoique ce soit
donc ça devrait être un peu considéré
comme ça étant entendu qu'il faut quand
même obligatoirement obligatoirement les
adapter un mois j'ai fait des
adaptations avec j monnet modeste
j'ai fait un petit sas d'entrée derrière
et j'ai fait un trou dans le mur avec
une table ici c'est une je me considère
lui comme une oeuvre une oeuvre s'est
pas vraiment fait pour évoluer c'est
quand même être fait pour être respecté
[Musique]
un radar ou choix jusque jusque là il
faudrait s'entendre sur ce qu'on entend
par une oeuvre d'art en soi alors oui
c'est une oeuvre architecturale donc l'
architecture c'est de l'art oui on
achète une avoir suite etc tu râles mais
derrière après est ce qu'on vit dans un
musée donc la mienne je l'avais j'ai dû
la payer dans les 135 mille euros mais
sur une maison il y avait encore il y
avait beaucoup de travail à faire certes
et des maisons entièrement réhabilité
semble-t-il il y en avait deux je me
rappelle qu'ils étaient en vente
une année plus tard elles étaient entre
300 mille quatre cent mille euros
je crois qu'il ya certains propriétaires
ont dû réaliser comment dire le
potentiel de plus value que pouvait
représenter une maison le corbusier
d'une certaine manière sans contrainte
et encore une fois ça change des jeux
j'y tenais que derrière je ne voyais pas
beaucoup
[Musique]
je commence à avoir l'habitude ah oui et
sans problème on n'y fait plus trop
attention puisque un aspect plaisant
qu'un camp sur le coup de minuit
11h30 minuit vous avez le talent mocky
par le fameux train espagnol
vous voyez passer dans devant votre
devant votre jardin vous voyez des gens
qui se promènent dans le wagon
restaurant de ce train là que vous vous
dites qu'ils vont vers l'espagne quelque
part vous dites mais voilà c'est la voix
de l'espagne ça fait tu sais c'est un
peu un rêve
le paradoxe c'est que la maison d'hakim
aïssaoui voisine de la maison classée
monument historique de william héros a
été largement modifié lors de son achat
hakim a bien été informé que la maison
se trouve dans une zone protégée
il s'est donc comme tout propriétaire
qu'il doit la restaurer et l'a ramené
vers son état d'origine sans toutefois
être dans l'obligation immédiate de
réaliser les travaux
c'est extrêmement important que cette
cité demeure une cité où les gens
viennent achètent vendent vive etc
par contre il faut aussi parce que
maintenant quiconque achète ici ne peut
pas ignorer ce qu'il achète donc de
savoir qu'il est là dans une oeuvre qui
le précède de près de 100 ans maintenant
et qui lui succédera et et donc il a un
devoir de respect du bâtiment qu'il va
acheter sinon vaut mieux aller acheter
ailleurs ou se faire construire pour
pouvoir être totalement libre
quand on achète ici il faut comprendre
que on achète aussi des contraintes et
qu'il va falloir les respecter parce que
cette oeuvre elle n'appartient pas
uniquement aux propriétaires de chaque
maison
elle nous appartient elle appartient à
la communauté qui l'a reconnu comme
patrimoine c'est exactement la même
chose que versailles
donc notre dame de paris donc ce sont
des bâtiments qui appartiennent à la
communauté française mais qui est même
maintenant aussi puisqu'il ya un projet
d'inscription sur la liste du patrimoine
mondial sont reconnus à une échelle
internationale
personne ne s'est préoccupé de cette
cité avant avant
je sais pas vont rester longtemps dans
les années soixante dix on a dû
commencer à vraiment posé la question de
savoir si on respectait la cité le
corbusier et si on l'a ramené à peu près
dans son état d'origine ou pas avant
c'était pas le problème est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est bien
c'est pour un ensemble architectural
c'est bien de ramener enfin dans les
meilleures conditions la maison à son
état initial je suis tout à fait
d'accord
si ce n'est qu' il ya des maisons qui
n'existerait plus comme celle de
monsieur guy dollé qui ne ressemblait
plus en rien qui n'a plus rien d'origine
et qui est tout à fait réussie et on a
comblé le vide qui étaient au dessous
puisque elle était logiquement sur
pilotis
quand on vous dit qu'une une baie vitrée
acier va me coûter six mille euros on
n'est plus dans le c'est dans la logique
des choses
quoi c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible de se dire qu'on va loger tous
types d'habitants dans une maison qui
était qui appartenait à une cité
ouvrière alors que si on doit s'en
référer à tout ce qui est d'origine
je sais pas je crois que je dois avoir 3
6 6 fenêtre dans lesquelles il faudrait
mettre 6000 euros par fenêtre je ne sais
pas qui peut faire ça je ne sais pas
c'est un souci donc je trouve qu'il
devrait y avoir certaine souplesse et
partir du moment où l'esthétique est
correct parce qu'on ramènera pas
l'oeuvre d'art à son point d'origine
faut pas rêver il faut pas possible
j'adore ce que fait le corbusier partir
où ça reste au musée comme que l'on va
visiter et je respecte tout ça mais
apparemment nous on veut continuer
habitués habiter dans une oeuvre qui
devrait être une oeuvre d'art c'est pas
compatible
pour moi ce n'est pas compatible parce
qu'il n'y a aucun arrangement dans une
maison corbusier est aujourd'hui
vivre sans changement c'est pas possible
c'est pas fonctionnel si on respectait
le corbusier
j'aurai la cuisine ici et j'aurais un
petit une petite pièce en entrée ce
qu'on appelle le boudoir est ici j'aurai
la pièce total voilà je n'aurais pas ce
que l'on aperçoit là au fond est ce que
vous dit rien donc voilà pour moi c'est
quasiment une dimension muséographique
c'est à dire que le problème c'est plus
l'habitat en lui dans lui-même c'est le
personnage de l'architecte le charisme
de l'architecte et ont l'âme la maison
devienne muséographie en quelque sorte
est totalement intellectuelle
intellectualiser pour le coup assez
éloigné d'une dune pour appeler de façon
un peu rapide la vraie vie la vraie vie
elle et n'essayez pas de faire votre
maison à l'image de celui qui l'a conçu
donc là on est dans une la quintessence
de l'intellectualisation et de du culte
rendu à un grand architecte par ailleurs
ski mais pour le coup la vie à l'échelle
1 la vie du quotidien
je pense qu'elle est dans une certaine
mesure trail et je pense aussi que le
concept initial de ce projet aurait
perçu cette trahison
burné médard et son mari ont habité ici
dès les années 60 puis sont partis après
de nombreuses années professionnelles
passées en afrique et le confort des
grands espaces
ils sont revenus vivre ici dans cette
petite maison sur quatre niveaux
c'est dire si le charme joue
discrètement au fil des années ils ont
rénové leur maison gratte-ciel en se
référant aux règles corbuséenne c'est
leur beau frère tim seulement qui nous
introduit dans la pensée de le corbusier
avec le concept de la machine à habiter
je suis très consciente d'habiter un
espace sa fin créé par une intelligence
original quoi enfin que tout est conçu
pour faire partie de l'homme du même
comment dirais-je toutes et tous fait
partie du dessin c'est pas uniquement
les fenêtres ou la cheminée et tout est
conçu comme une machine à vivre si vous
voulez je suis pas drac quel point c je
ne sais pas à quel point c'est ça que ça
marche ça fonctionne très bien comme
machine exactement à vivre mais du point
de vue esthétique c'est très désagréable
c'est pas trop qu'est ce que ça veut
dire machines à habiter c'est
l'efficacité qu'est ce que ça veut dire
cette machine et c'est pas trop il
s'agit pas pour lui de faire une
architecture qui ressemble à des
machines et de ce point de vue là sa
phrase la maison est une machine à
habiter a été très mal interprété on a
cru qu il voulait faire dé des maisons
qui ressemble à des machines pas du tout
la question est construisons nos maisons
comme les ingénieurs construisent des
machines c'est à dire en raisonnant de
manière logique rationnelle et c'est
cette pensée là qu'il veut appliquer à
l' architecture donc le monde de
l'ingénieur le monde des automobiles le
monde des avions le monde des grands
transatlantiques qui sont les grands
domaines d'innovation à cette époque là
sont des modèles mais des modèles avant
tout méthodologique
non
[Musique]
et vous avez aussi sur les terrasses qui
sont et un solarium des jardins
suspendus la possibilité d'en créer donc
eh bien on va avoir ici une nature qui
entrent en dialogue finalement maxxo
m'attire la nature par définition c'est
tout à fait contraire de ce bâti
guéant
[Musique]
alors nous venons quitter l'espace
technique un espace de services l'espace
dédié et on arrive ici à l'espace jours
dans l'espace jour de la maison 1
la pièce à vivre en fait l'idée de nous
faire entrer par ici c'est nous faire
entrer par la diagonale de la pièce la
diagonale de la pièce c'est la dimension
la plus grande donc le convier joue avec
nous ils veulent
il va vraiment tourner créer son
architecture autour de l'homme 1 autour
de l'humain l'idée étant vraiment de
faire en sorte que cette ce bien-être
soit soit effectif grâce à cette
architecture qu'on va voir autour de soi
on fait même chose avec la avec la
cheminée d'ailleurs cette cheminée si on
l'a d'école du mur c'est non seulement
pour créer des espaces différents mais
c'est aussi pour moduler l'espace quand
vous êtes ici quand vous êtes dans cette
pièce et que vous bougez dans la pièce
la cheminée si elle ne bouge pas elle
change quand même deux cadres
visuellement vous la fait changer de
cadre et ça ça anime la pièce un autre
intérêt de déco et cette cheminée c'est
le chauffage tout simplement
c'est un peu regardez je suis bien au
milieu des fleurs l'agent lève toutes
les fleurs fanées pour de façon à ce
qu'il y ait de belles pousses après les
garder un petit peu d'auteurs mais pas
trop quand même pour pouvoir avoir une
vue quand même sur le quartier on n'est
pas là pour se confiner si les habitants
n'ont pas toujours respectées ou compris
la façon dont le corbusier avait conçu
ses maisons ses maisons ont un potentiel
d'évolution d'adaptation
qui montre que ce n'est pas un échec une
maison elle n'est jamais fait pour pour
rester figé
donc les gens vont la faire évoluer
votre transformé c'est dans la logique
des choses
alors aujourd'hui par contre ça pose des
problèmes de patrimoine de conservation
parce que justement on est maintenant
dans un ensemble qui est reconnue
internationalement et donc les la
question de la protection du respect des
formes etc et des intérieurs se pense
sylvie habite une des quatre maisons
rénovées par l'office public hlm
aquitanis un bailleur social qui a
redonné en maison le corbusier couleurs
et formes d origine
j'entendais parler de ce court billet
chez même pas qui était ce monsieur et
après ben quand j'ai vu l' architecture
judaïsme c'est superbe
j'adore et puis bon il faut quand même
pas s'enlever de la tête l'année parce
que bon c'est cézanne dans les années
une fin des années 20 quand même faut
voir quand même quand vous voyez qu'il y
avait des garages qui avait été fait
alors que les gens n'avaient pas de
voiture
des salles de bain alors que j'ai un
souvenir que ma grand mère a fait sa
première salle de bains dans les années
60 quand même ça donne c'était vraiment
avant gardiste à l'époque
moi ça m'a plu parce que savez ce style
un petit peu je dirais méditerranéen du
moins plus cotés maroc et c'est vrai que
quand je suis sur ma terrasse elle a
déjà rien que les tons la couleur brique
l'a déjà c'est vrai ça fait vraiment
passé au soleil l'évasion
on est dans un autre monde
c'est le même programme social qui
permet à frédéric est versée leers
d'habiter dans une maison le corbusier
comme si le projet initial d'henri
frugès retrouver une deuxième jeunesse
avec les femmes contemporaines d'habiles
terre vous a proposé c'était une demande
de logement social
et ça a été le premier logement
finalement comme l'a proposé la première
chose que j'ai vu c'était que c'était à
côté d'une voie ferrée donc j'ai dit ah
non non je veux pas habiter à côté nous
va ferrer sont hors de question et puis
c'est vrai qu'on avait toujours habité
dans un appartement vous proposer une
maison avec un jardin un prix très
abordable
du coup on se dit bon on va voir le
quartier ce que ça donne au moins avant
de donner une réponse
et quand on est arrivés dans le quartier
on s'est aperçu que c'était la cité
frugès comme ceux qu'on connaît qu'on ne
connaissait pas et en bordelais on
savait même pas que il y avait une
citer le corbusier à pessac du coup on
est tombé sous le charme mais à
l'instant même
on est rentré on a vu ces espaces verts
ou et puis le train est passé
complètement en arrière plan et et puis
finalement s'y fait très bien
[Musique]
malgré les apparences les solutions de
rénovation du quartier sont loin d'être
trouvé les de nombreux problèmes
subsistent
grosse difficulté d'où la cité frugès
c'est que c'est un quartier qui est vécu
comme par chacun des propriétaires comme
une maison individuelle et où la
dimension d'ensemble n'est absolument
pas perçu pour ce qu'elle est c'est
difficile pour un propriétaire de
comprendre qu'il appartient à un
ensemble plus grand que lui même et qu'à
un moment mais il faut peut-être que il
accepte un certain nombre de règles qui
n'étaient pas les siennes en arrivant
moi je pense que le schéma idéal c'est
la restitution à un moment tout le
talent fait un choix un choix de
restitution totale aller jusqu'au bout
dirai jamais que cinquante maisons
avant
dans les années 70 on voulait détruire
cette cité 50 maisons 50 machines à
habiter organisé autour de trois rues ou
des arcades rue andré frugès et rue le
corbusier
aujourd'hui la cité est sauvé de
nombreuses maisons sont classés ou
inscrits au titre des monuments
historiques
une nouvelle demande au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco se prépare
alors le bonheur de vivre dans les
quartiers modernes frugès quintilla la
machine à habiter à cet assemblage
subtil des formes et des volumes au jeu
entre le soleil le ciel les arbres
l'acier le ciment à la valse concrète
des formes et des volumes sous la
lumière
le corbusier aurait-il inventé il ya
presque cent ans un modèle d'habitat
qu'il faut protéger à tout prix dans ses
formes d'origine le rénové à l'identique
faute de pouvoir si moh conserver sa
magie
l' architecture nous tous chez nous
n'est dans un état de jouissance grâce à
sa consonance avec les lois de l'univers
une profondeur sans borne s'ouvre efface
les murs accompli le miracle de l'espace
indicible le couronnement de les notions
plastique
l'architecturé de l'ordre du sacré à
condition de vivre confortablement
[Musique]
beaucoup
un an
[Musique]
en